yeah it's interesting also too that you
would think you would find happiness
in in um not goal scoring but like I
noticed in my own life in the past two
years since I spoke to you last you know
I've probably had some a decent amount
of success and life kind of got a little
bit more exciting with doing some
touring and um you know was more
financially rewarding and I always but I
found that I was
really not unhappy I was grateful but I
was I guess I was a little unhappy I
think I always felt like when I got to a
certain level of
success that the questions that I had
inside of my heart or inside of my brain
or the the discomfort I felt like
everything would go away like like life
would hand me some like like magic
answer book that had a couple decent
answers in it you know but that mean
like Beyond order yeah yes yes like
Beyond order like there would be okay
you did it you know like somebody comes
out from behind the door and they're
like all right bucko you know like
finally Oz comes out you know and um
right but it and says good job but that
never happens no no well you know that's
that's another indication of of the
perverseness of human beings to some
degree so look there are there are two
kinds of reward technically speaking
there's satisfaction and there's
incentive reward and satisfaction is the
reward that you were sort of dreaming
about it's it's the so you're hungry and
you have Thanksgiving dinner and you're
no longer hungry that's a reward that's
satiation it's satisfying it it stops
you from being hungry well you think
well I'm hungry I don't want to be
hungry anymore but hunger did give you
something to do and there was the
anticipation of the meal you know and
sometimes on Thanksgiving Day people
will not eat all day just to heighten
the anticipation right because that that
increases the incentive reward and
incentive reward is what you experience
when you're moving towards a desired
goal rather than when you attain it and
we do have this Vision it's a vision of
utopia and probably is what motivates
utopian thinking motivates ideas of the
promised land which is milk and honey
that if we just turn the corner and get
to here everything will be all right
yeah and that that isn't the case um
we're we're wired up so that the Pursuit
is often more engaging than the than the
acquisition yeah I wish I had to realize
that though as I was trying to acquire I
didn't there were Mo it's like it's such
a tough thing I I missed some of the
moments of the pursuit because I was so
focused on I think on this in goal that
would make any of the uncomfort or all
it would make all the pain of the the
sacrifice it would make it all worth it
kind of right right right well that that
there is some utility in that sort of
dream too because it having that image
of the future also motivates you to
pursue it but the problem with that kind
of thinking I suppose too is that this
is dovi raised this in Notes from
Underground it's a great short book and
he it's short I'll give it a chance man
if it's a great book it's a great book
it's really it's a real punch that book
and it contains a very P powerful
critique of the idea of utopia and dovi
and he was talking about the sort of
precursors to the Russian Communists and
their notion if you just gave everybody
enough material resources then all of a
sudden the problems of the world would
disappear dovi first of all points out
that that's nonsense because um for
reasons that are similar to the ones
that you laid out but also that even if
it was true people are so perverse in a
sense we such peculiar creatures that we
would smash our happiness all to pieces
out of sheer boredom just so something
new and exciting could happen so that we
would have something to do again and I
read that and I thought wow that's
exactly right it's that it's this
searching that's part of our essential
nature is not only insatiable but it's
actually
desirable because well what do you do
you shake hands with Oz and then you die
it's like done I'm over well you don't
because you want to get on to the next
great adventure and so it is I you know
The Sermon on the Mount seems to address
this to me this fundamental problem and
my reading of it anyways is something
like um align yourself with the highest
good that you're capable of imagining
and so for all intents and purposes
that's God the sum total of all that's
good and you live in relationship to
that and then concentrate on the
moment and see it it seems to me that
way you get to have your cake and eat it
too right because you're aiming at
something that's like the promised land
this proverbial Utopia it's it by
definition is the best possible thing
and maybe your view of that's going to
change as you mature but it doesn't
matter that's still going to orient you
and having that in mind so now you're
pointing in the right direction you can
attend very carefully to the details of
the pursuit and that's I think that's
that's the best we can do well I I
certainly haven't well it did come from
The Sermon on the Mount so
hypothetically it's a reliable source
you know but I think it makes a
tremendous amount of sense
psychologically yeah I mean why would
you not aim at the best that you could
conceptualize if you were going to aim
right um and having done that well then
it is reasonable to concentrate on the
present and then you can then you can
immerse yourself in the present and
enjoy
it